all right we got the doctor light
parallel we got the Megaman parallel we
can make a Mega Man movie now right like
it looks like we can I don't know if
it'll be good but I now saw the variant
characters on screen so I feel like we
can make that I don't know what came
first Mega Man or Aleta the manga I
don't know just Standish thought a Mega
Man it's worth looking up hold on the
reason to run December 15 1990 so [ __ ]
yeah
it's totally like Mega Man
[Music]
Elita battle angels so will lead a
battle angel is a movie produced by
james cameron directed by robert
rodriguez based on an old manga I
haven't read the manga so if I critique
something in this movie like oh they did
they're saying it didn't make sense I
thought it was stupid
and it happened that way in the original
books I haven't read it I'm just
critiquing how I saw it on screen the
story is is 25 something pretty far in
the future there was a big war a couple
hundred years prior to changed the
landscape of the entire earth basically
as I understand it as its presented in
the movie there's this shitty city and
then there's this awesome city that's
hovering above the shitty city so
everyone in the lower City is like why
are we in this [ __ ] we want to be up
there everyone up there you feel like
they're like the high society people
they're kind of running the show but
there's a lot of people are cyborgs now
they have these cyber enhancements like
to the point where you're like are you
mostly machine yes you are Christoph
Waltz as characters doctor he finds his
cyborg and he's like oh you're special
and you're alive and I kind of want a
daughter again so he gives her a body
she has amnesia it's like their father
and daughter but she's more than meets
the eye a lot of people want to kill her
and so she's really good at fighting
that's pretty much that's my take away
let me talk about the thing that is to
talk about in this movie most and that's
the visuals oh my god the visuals in
this movie are insane they make for an
interesting world exciting fight
sequences this is some damn good CGI
it's really impressive man white always
impresses me between wata and ILM I've
always thought Ladda was more
photorealistic
visually they've always impressed me
they've always upped the game and they
do it here too and like I said the fight
sequences were really exciting this girl
just beats ass this is what she does
there's one bar brawl in particular I
was like I'm entertained as hell I even
like the character interactions leading
up to it the tension just fed right into
it this world is an interesting world it
does feel like a lived-in world whenever
I watch a movie like this if it's on
another world or in the future or
something I always think to myself do I
want to live here what I like to be here
usually no because there aren't the
conveniences we have in our world but
damn it if I wasn't like probably be
kind of fun Christoph Waltz's character
and Alita their dynamic together they
were just they brought the heart it was
a really sweet story between those two
that I like watching as I was watching
it Rosa Salazar plays her she's just a
charming character there's something
about her bright-eyed naivety towards
people she's just she's a positive
person or cyborg and I always like it
when people that positive have to fight
with people that positive have to see
the darker side of humanity is have it
crush their dream don't really buy the
romance between her and the do didn't
really stick the landing for
just didn't and some of the actors I
felt were wasted Jennifer Connelly could
have been played by anybody mahuri Lally
one of the go-to if not best actors
working right now and again this is kind
of wasted in the moon could've been
played by a myriad of people I was
thinking all right if this movie sucks I
feel like my Hershel alley
will totally raúl juliá this thing that
is raúl juliá from Street Fighter where
it's like he totally elevates the movie
and I will argue anybody on that fact he
totally does but not my Hershel alley
he's good but he's just there again I
feel like he could have been played by
one of many people and this movie deals
with this is one of those things from
like the manga had to have touched on
this it's a pretty beloved series and I
refuse to believe the beloved series is
oh hey here's a story about a girl who
can't lose a fight so what do you have a
system that's like Oh high society in
the floating city and then everyone
dwelling in the [ __ ] you can touch
on some deeper themes of social dynamics
social constructs also with the cyborg
girl you know being the star of it and
other people with cybernetic implants
what makes us human I touch on it and
critique it because it's not like these
themes aren't in here they're here to a
superficial level but they never really
hit them home to a cerebral degree I
don't like for the movie to go a little
deeper this story because I've seen the
collection of books I don't know how
much of it they crammed into this one
movie but I feel like it was a lot so
this movie runs into what a lot of
stories in it shoes run into which is we
want to cram as much of the story in
this one movie as possible if it flows
or not and really the story would have
benefited being an HBO show or something
to have 12 hours to really dedicate to
the story but at that point the show
wouldn't have looked as impressive as
the movie day so the visuals would take
a hit but the storytelling would be
better I would prefer the storytelling
over the visuals and as it stands the
movie feels very cramped and also Aleta
never loses a fight she never loses a
fight I kind of half take that back
there was one fight where she's in
pretty bad shape by the end of it but
she still doesn't lose the fight I don't
know if it's a spoiler to say she never
loses a fight she's in bad shape but she
never had that moment of having to
retreat like don't can't fight that
person now because that's a level 60 I'm
a little 10 got to crawl away go down a
drain or something and hopefully come
back it's like if he had Superman but no
kryptonite at that point you got to give
them the tough decisions there are a
couple of tough decisions if I'm
actually thinking back to it with those
tough decisions never maybe like oh my
god that's dark that's a decision they
have to make not like she had to choose
between this town getting nuked or the
fault line getting split without the
ability to fly around earth
words and reversed time now she's just
badass she's iddqd and doom badass
that's pretty fun I've done that I've
done the god mode coding alright let's
just waste demons but then I eventually
get sick of it and like all right I want
the thrill of possibly losing that
thrill that's not even in here like if
you think back to a really old show that
got cancelled called daredevil the
reason I like daredevil as daredevil got
his ass beat quite a few times he had to
tuck tail and run away like I got a
retreat can't do that right now know at
a point she's just unstoppable she gets
the Mario star she's like my ninja moves
I made them up myself just now but
there's a difference between strong
female character and unstoppable watch
that monologue and Angus in fact I will
put that link below if it exists on
YouTube does that monologue George see
Scott has in the movie Angus about
Superman I've heard it many times but
that's where I first heard it so that's
where I'm pointing to so in the end
Alita battle angel I enjoy it's visually
impressive it's exciting it has
surprising amount of heart and humor but
I felt some of the actors were wasted
some of the themes that could have
touched on they didn't I am interested
to see more from this world though so I
hope it'll get a sequel but it all
depends on the box office so we'll see
felt like I ripped into this movie more
than I meant to sorry I don't mean to do
that just when you say something's great
you can just be like oh yeah that was
cool moving on gotta break down the
negatives more than the positives in
order to justify it that's why sometimes
negatives they take up more space so if
you're coming to this movie for great
visuals exciting fights in an
interesting world to live in while it's
all going down I mean elite is fine it's
good entertainment in the end I will say
elite at battle angel was a good time no
alcohol required it starts off really
intriguing and ends a little rough
around the edges but still a fun time
it's all I can ask for all right so will
lead up battle angel have you seen it
what you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]